[Music]
well it's important every so often to
take a good look at the curriculum see
what you're doing and to decide what to
do for the future and the last time the
department really did this on a
comprehensive basis was in 1970 so we
decided that in 1986 and 87 it was time
again to take another look at the
curriculum and if I could have the first
slide this is these are the members of
the committee who conducted the study
committee of about nine faculty members
who had the following goals if I could
have the next slide the goal of the
study which took place over the year
eight 1986-87 was first to conduct a
comprehensive review of our present
curriculum and the future needs and then
more important to lead the faculty in a
process of evaluation and change from
the beginning we thought it was not
enough simply to analyze the curriculum
and issue a report but to actually
develop an action plan or an
implementation plan that would then lead
us to some of the changes you're going
to hear from Professor Sean and Meryl
the committee worked all year and then
at the end of the year we had a session
at Endicott House in which we have the
whole faculty present to review the
results and mutually agree on the
direction to proceed connect the next
slide well as Clarke mentioned the
process that we established and looking
at what we were doing was threefold
first to review the results of the
numerous studies that were under
way then on the future of chemical
engineering and professor way has given
some examples of the the amundsen report
which was a very important study there
were a number of other studies underway
at that time the University of Texas had
an important study we essentially
collected all of the articles that
talked about the crises the future
opportunities and assimilated the
information then the second thing we did
was to survey the alumni from the
classes of 70 75 80 and 85 and I'm sure
there are people here in the room who
responded to that questionnaire and
finally we then analyzed the curriculum
if I could have the next slide
well the alumni survey asked a number of
questions but first we asked them how
their careers had progressed since they
left MIT our goal here in them in the
marketing context was to to survey the
customers of our product and find out
how they were using it and basically we
gave the the respondents gave what would
amount to a resume showing us how they
had progressed since they left MIT we
asked them what were the five most
significant accomplishments we asked
them of what was most valuable about
through MIT and what was most lacking
from their MIT education I'll talk first
about this question of how their careers
progress as you can imagine the data was
very diverse trying to put some order in
to all the various events that had
happened to people and so the approach
that we use has shown on the next slide
like any chemical engineer was to
construct a a flow sheet and this is an
example of the results of the survey
from the class of 1980 it's not totally
typical
because 1980 was an unusual year there
were plentiful jobs for chemical
engineers enrollments were at an all
time
hi but I'm going to use this as an
example to show you some of the
differences between the results from the
other class the first thing we notice
that it's out of a hundred percent of
the bachelors graduates in that
particular year and unusually large
percent went right to work in industry
the others smaller group went into
graduate school at that time and then
medicine and law also picked up a
significant portion of the graduates but
then a rather interesting thing happened
after these people went into employment
you'll notice they then pursued their
graduate education so that as of today
or as of 1986 the number who were still
working without any further education
was only at that time 29% and this is
going to continue to change I predict as
more and more of these continue their
education the differences between the
earlier classes of 75 and 70 we that in
those years the number that went
directly to work after graduating was
only about 25 percent and by the time of
the survey in every case in both of
those classes there were in fact no
respondents who had not gotten some
graduate degree beyond their MIT
education so the bottom line is the
four-year degree is not the end point
for any of our graduates and if they
don't even those that go directly to
work will generally continue their
education at some later point so we're
really preparing students to learn I
wish time permitted me to share some of
the detailed significant accomplishments
that the respondents presented it's
really impressive to see the breadth of
responsibilities and achievements that
were that were made we found out that
about of the class of 1970 about
two-to-one ratio in terms of management
versus technical careers at that time
for the others it was split at about
5050 at that point I should say the
class of 1985 was - they there could
their careers had not progressed at all
and so we saw only the initial result
and at that time by the way the
percentage had returned back to 25% who
went directly to work okay if I could
skip on to the next slide and then
continue on we asked him what were the
most valuable aspects of their MIT
education and to a person they but for
all the classes it was remarkably
consistent that we saw these things
listed as the most important first this
ability to learn to think quickly and
logically that was so overwhelming that
it was really really remarkable the
breadth of courses that they took so
their breadth of training was was
extremely important the fact that they
learned discipline hard work how to
learn and then finally the MIT
reputation and contacts and the people
they met when they were here there was
no difference between the class of 70
the class of 85 this was consistent
across the board throughout their career
if we look at the things they found most
lacking though there was a very
significant difference between the more
recent classes and the earlier ones if I
could see the next slide the things from
the classes of 80 and 85 that they felt
were most missing were practical
real-world problems
they mentioned unit operations they
mentioned use of computers they
mentioned Career Guidance these were all
things that engineers write out on
graduates nearly on the job would face
in terms of their needs if we looked at
the earlier classes though 70 and 75 on
the next slide they didn't they didn't
miss any of those earlier things they
didn't miss the unit operations or the
computers what they were missing were
communication skills business training
and liberal arts now I don't think our
curriculum changed during the time
between 70 and 75 and 80 and 85 to
account for this instead what it
presents is the evolving careers of the
graduates and the needs they find in the
later stages of their career
these are the things that they find most
important when they're just getting
started the things mentioned on the
previous slide were the ones that were
most important if I could have the next
slide well in addition to doing the
alumni survey and surveying the studies
underway we also took a very detailed
analysis of our curriculum we broke all
of the subjects that required subjects
in not only chemical engineering but
also chemistry physics mathematics we
broke them up into basic elementary
modules and we conduct can we
constructed a giant map if you will of
the whole curriculum showing all the
concepts that were taught in the course
is how they interrelated with each other
and where they led to and the conclusion
of this well there was there was one
thing that was very obvious it's not
listed on the slide was the large number
of things that students learned as an
undergraduate maybe in physics courses
mathematics courses that never seemed to
be used anywhere else and at first we
thought well maybe that indicates
something is redundant that could be
left out but as we began to think of it
if nothing was redundant and left out
that forms the structure of the skeleton
on which as they as they later are going
to build and so even though everything
is not covered in the education it can
very well be used later but we concluded
that the basic curriculum was sound the
fundamentals were there and needed some
minor tuning it needed a change in a few
courses but basically the concept was
fine we were very concerned about
whether we should have a computer
requirement as we look though we found
that about 85% of the students elect a
computer course anyway and so instead
what we needed was a computer
proficiency requirement that would still
give the students a chance to learn
computing and whatever way they might
choose from the courses at the Institute
and since the number of required
subjects is very limited
it certainly didn't make sense to make a
requirement of something at every one
anyway and then finally there was the
conclusion that we needed to integrate
education in the context of the more
diverse real world problems one of the
obvious results of all these earlier
studies was that chemical engineers are
moving into a much broader range of
applications we need to find some way to
be able to integrate those applications
into their education and there was a big
move underfoot also and I should mention
this is Institute wide to improve the
educational process by putting more
technology in the context of the total
problem and this then led to the concept
of integrated chemical engineering and I
think I should say that this concept
actually was first originated by
Professor herb Shawn and following the
the publication of this report herb has
then taken the lead in the
implementation plan and he'll talk about
that next thank you
[Applause]
could I have the first slide please what
I'm going to be talking about is
basically something that I mentioned in
a committee meeting to be provocative
and what you're going to see is the
results of the of the committee after
that which is certainly quite different
than what was suggested but I think
achieves the goals that we're trying to
accomplish what we're talking about is
integrated chemical engineering and
that's the concept that Jim Wei
purported the real goal of who are
trying to do is to better teach the
fundamentals of chemical engineering not
to radically change the concepts or what
needs to be taught but to do a better
job the needs we are trying to address
is to reduce course dependent learning
learning where a student learns a
concept of transport in one course but
does not readily carry that over to work
in say a reactor design course or
another course we saw that there was a
course dependency the students did not
carry material which they understood in
one course to another course also to
give students some experiment experience
in working with synthetic problems
rather than an analysis that is dealing
with large complex problems which have
ambiguities dealing with the entire
picture and from that having to come up
with a solution something which is not
commonly involved in problems in our
normal courses also we wanted to present
our fundamental materials in the context
of how they might be used in industry in
addition we want to develop
problem-solving skills particularly the
definition of the problem how you take
this large complex problem with both
this technological and social
consequences and define what really the
problem is that you ought to be working
on also to identify the background who
you need the skills which you need to
solve such a problem whether you need to
hire consultants or whether you need to
learn more material and the notion of
continuing education that basically what
we get at MIT is education that is not
going to stop we have to do both self
education and additional class work
education after the student gets out of
MIT and we want to enhance their
professional awareness that is let them
see some industrial problems gives them
some experience some ideas about new
fields and opportunities and the social
context in which those problems will be
cast next slide please
the concept of the ice the integrated
chemical engineering is basically based
upon industrial problem-solving the
concept is this is the way that chemical
engineers and industry would solve a
problem you have a library of books the
books which you've learned from sitting
on a shelf and so that we have a library
that the text or the course does not
follow along a text but we have a group
of texts which the students have
purchased from that we're going to use
those to solve the set of problems we're
going to solve a series of cases which
are about one month in duration so the
students will see five or six cases with
which they solve these are posed to the
students at the beginning of each module
as a fairly ill-defined complex problem
the first week or sold class several
weeks of class is really in identifying
a strategy for solution what is the
problem what can we do what are all the
different angles about the consequences
of the solution based on that you
identify what you want to do you
identify the background information that
you must acquire and that background
information using this library book
is taught much in the same way that we
now teach our courses we take chapters
from those books acquire the necessary
background the homework and quizzes are
given normal fashion the problems are
largely centered around the solution of
this case case topics are picked to
emphasize some of the current problems
such as waste treatment biotechnology
microelectronics pollution product
development things which we have trouble
incorporating within our standard text
and the standards examples given within
the text let me note that this is
different than a case study type of
approach in that we're not just
analyzing somebody else's solution the
class is really going through the
solution process themselves so it's not
a case study it's not a case analysis
it's really doing a project as a class
next slide please
the implementation of the ice is
basically we've developed two senior
courses they replace the existing
chemical design course and subsumed that
we are presently going through a trial
class it was mentioned that Kimmy was
started with eleven students well we
have eight 200 years later embarking on
this endeavor next year it will be an
optional subject offering after we get
the bugs out of of this year and in
1990-91 it's going to be required for
the Kami curriculum next slide this is a
list of the example of the projects that
are going to be taught in the the
preliminary the test case this year
production of acetic anhydride from
acetone and acetic acid this is going to
be taught by professor george
stephanopolous will encompass many of
the standard design type concepts the
concept and the practice of design with
an example of the
chemical process industry ii is a
production of trial size of batches of
monomer for a market trial of a
particular polymeric material this
brings in not only the process design
involved in a batch process but also the
engineering economics the third is a
drug delivery system for brain cancer
this will be taught by Bob Langer
centered around some of his current
research and will teach advanced
transport kinetics product design
concepts the fourth one I'll leave that
for ED Merrill to discuss he's going to
be following on and go through what is
typically happening in this this is a
product development where we're
developing a product that he calls Polly
beads for a novel separation processes
the fifth case project is a cleanup of a
toxic waste dump this is going to be
taught jointly by John Ehrenfeld and a
lacerum Seraphim it deals with the
modeling and the understanding of a
waste dump how it's similar to that of a
packed bed brings in the concepts of
that it also deals with how you extract
the chemicals from such a waste waste
dump and then process them to take care
of the toxic materials and all the
societal and political implications
involved with this sort of cleanup
endeavor next slide the fundamentals
that to repeat the fundamentals that are
being taught are the fundamentals of
process design advanced transport and
reactor design the synthetic
problem-solving that is the dealing of
large with large complex problems that
have boundary conditions associated not
only with technological but with
societal implementations also product
development something that we don't see
in most chemical engineering standard
curriculums engineering you can
comics process control next slide some
of the attributes of this approach are
really that we're ma we can modify our
curriculum by the content by the the
projects which we choose for these
modules so it allows us for the
curriculum to easily evolve as as the
needs evolve so that we don't have a
stagnant curriculum there is a potential
of writing modular tests there's a great
barrier to writing the text materials
because it involves a lot of time but
the concept of writing a smaller text
that accounts for one of these case
projects is not such a onerous task and
we're hoping that will propagate it
involves all the faculty or most the
faculty talking about their current
research and I think this is one of the
things that made chemical engineering
very exciting in 1920 is the people
teaching the classes we're talking about
their research and the evolving concepts
and that's what we hope to inject into
these courses faculty are much better
when they're talking about their
research in record it requires I've got
to be careful I'm the junior person of
here
the only non poll professor giving a
talk this morning so I've got to be
careful it also requires a greater
teaching net effort we're talking about
two semesters in which we have eight
faculty very much involved so it's a
greater teaching effort and we're trying
to have greater contact between the
student and feel that anytime when we
have good contact between the students
and the faculty very good things happen
thank you very much the next talk will
be given by Ed Merrill talking about his
module to give you an example of what's
going to go into these courses
[Applause]
and before I present the module that
herb Sean asked me to consider doing in
this program I'd like to make a few
comments first this is a wild experience
for me because it's like the television
program this is your life I have met
students from the last 38 years of my
service on the MIT faculty and it's it's
amazing to think how many of them
remember me not for what I taught them
but for the bizarre things like the
Alice in Wonderland stories and so on I
don't know as I taught him anything that
was really engineering but they didn't
remember some jokes as far as as far as
age is concerned Herbst on points out
his youthfulness and I am reminded of
the fact that and and by Jimmy way of
birthdays that my birthday happens to
coincide with the birthday of that great
text by Walker Lewis and McAdams called
principles of chemical engineering we
both came out in the same year
and and furthermore I'm reminded of the
fact through Hoyts and Fritz's
allocution to you that I am a curiously
a connector in this conference because
in point of fact like I am a chemical
engineer and came to serve on the MIT
faculty and be a student at MIT in the
Graduate School precisely because of
William Henry McAdams who gave a course
in chemical engineering in the chemistry
department at Harvard where I was a
student and it is to dr. Lewis that I
had my first plunge in being a research
assistant for a professor who had very
strong ideas is touted research was
going to be carried out and boy did he
tell me how to do it
Marilee said damn it shut up a minute
let me talk and and so we would have
this graceful dialogue and we were funny
it was with Fritz Meisner that I was
first a student in his chemical
engineering thermodynamics 1040 where I
unwittingly served as a foil as a kind
of a foolscap I would say the stupidest
things in the class would laugh and
Fritz would play along with it I don't
know why I did that but anyhow it led us
to a very happy relationship because I
then became his teaching assistant in
the course which was called industrial
chemistry of colloidal and amorphous
materials which was written by Walker
Lewis Walker I'm sorry Lewis broken and
Squires dr. Lewis broken and Squires
Jeff broken in in LOM Squires
and that was effectively of course
partly in college partly in polymers
despite its name and that led me to
carry out my doctoral research under the
direction of Fritz Meisner and taught me
principles I've never forgotten and I
also should acknowledge of course the
tremendous help of Ed Gilliland and as
dr. Lewis as my mentors when I was first
on the faculty in 1950 coming back as a
young timid
Oh terrified young fellow trying to
teach a class and absolutely terrified
by the whole thing and both Gilliland
and Louis gave me tremendous guidance
and continue to do throughout their our
association now to get to the purpose
what I'm here to talk to you about let
me have the first slide please
integrated chemical engineering and the
next slide on American do it next slide
I run it backwards and say first it
should be engineering based on science
using science of course but
fundamentally engineering not science
secondly it should have something to do
with chemistry in it and thirdly it
should be integrated and it should be
integrated not only in respect to the
technological pots but also in the
larger context of economics industry and
societal responsibility the slides keep
melding this money I don't know what
that phenomenon is there's something
very interesting going on you see this
advantage that cloud develops at a
certain time we better go on to the next
slide before I'm going to present an
overview of concepts involved in what
herbs on suggested I take on namely a
module that involves process development
and product development in combination
and the details of this will be
developed of course in the interaction
with the class of students it's it's not
set in concrete at this point in time
but as you see there are a number of
issues that we can take on and discuss
as a class and work on and to a
significant degree I've conceived this
module as a result not only of my
experience in industry before I came
back to MIT but also industrial
associations since that time and in
particular with my current graduate
students who are involved in my
laboratory
some of them working on problem
very closely related to this and I hope
that when they see what I'm about to say
they won't break out in hysterical
laughter now if going on the next slide
we present the poly beam corporation to
you and we're the new product
development department there are and you
as the students in this class have as
your initial charge to develop bead like
particles as yet undefined which can
become suspended in a liquid mixture
bind to their surfaces only a targeted
species but no other species in other
words they are specific and not general
in their capacity to binding and finally
be removed by a simple and fast
separation process embodied therein in
those three requirements our whole
spectrum of technological issues next
slide please
and as a first scheme we have to focus
in on what what really is the purpose of
developing these bead like particles
before we can address this second
immediate zone which are the immediate
technical issues and having done that we
go out into the broader technical issues
and then finally into issues that are
Supra technical they go beyond it they
involve it but they go beyond it and so
to take next slide please
the issue of mission focus this the
central issue of the key issue to start
with at least in this development what
do we want to do next slide please
are the beads to be developed as a
diagnostic test for example are they to
be aimed at detecting human immune virus
are they supposed to harvest what they
are going after capture it but allowing
it to be recovered subsequently as for
example protein a on a surface will
harvest monoclonal
anybody and you want the monocle on
anybody back but you don't want for
example anti-v destruction you don't
want the human immune virus back you
want to know that it's there then you
want to kill it is it to be used as as a
form of simple purification of a liquid
mixture and having addressed the issues
of the product objective what we want
the beads for next slide please
which I've already given you some
indication of this it indicates that we
have to think about the the target of
this in terms of its size and its
molecular properties is it an antibody
of molecular weight or the order of
$100,000
is it a chromium ion is it a viral
particle it can be seen in hundred
transmission electron microscope or even
a scanning electron microscope is it a
blood platelet which is 1 micron across
the scale of the size of this will
certainly make a tremendous difference
in what we decide the bead should be to
capture this particular target next
slide please
that then brings up the next ring the
immediate technical issues involved in
proceeding with the development of the
bead like product next slide please
first thing of course is what are the
properties of a liquid environment
acidic basic if the bead obviously is
something that will dissolve an acid in
the medium is acid you haven't got any
any bead to worry about it's gone if the
solution is very high density and the
bead is a very low density obviously
it's going to be impossible to keep the
bead in the solution so that the very
question of suspending beads involves
the concept of having something near
neutrally buoyant and therefore some
fluid mechanics comes into it as well as
in the question of viscous if the fluid
is extremely viscous we'd have to think
about how the beads what size they
should be in order to separate them
subsequently
and so this will involve the discussion
you see cutting across many physical and
chemical parameters to make the decision
as to subsequently how we're going to
separate but before we come to that next
slide please yes we're some processing
gets it into the picture
what should the feed like particles be
formed from my one of my areas of
interest is polymer synthesis and so it
would be natural for me to think about
cross-linking styrene with dye vinyl
benzene or making nylon by in the facial
polymerization but was in concert with
my colleagues in ceramics we might also
think about making beads of silica or
alumina or magnetite especially if we
want the magnetic part of it as a means
of separation subsequently or we might
make the beads composite by having one
species say magnetite embedded in a
polystyrene capsule and should they be
for example solid completely solid or
should they be micro porous and if so
what should it be the pore size there's
no point in having a micro porous of
we're trying to harvest blood platelets
because they're already one micron
across what should be the what size
range do we require should they be fixed
in size or do we have a permissible size
range in distribution but clearly we'll
be in trouble if we have a distribution
ranging over three orders of magnitude
say the the beads range from 0.1 micron
up to a thousand microns because then
separation would be almost impossible we
address these issues in terms of the way
we're going to make them but let me show
you as an example of needs and next
slide please our beads made for the
purpose of chromatographic separations
on a very large scale a micro porous
that made for size exclusion
chromatography and they have a
remarkably close distribution of sizes
as you can see from the bar sizing these
beads are approximately 10 to 15 microns
in diameter
and this is the kind of bead-like
product when we're thinking about but
the question is what is the size and
should it be porous a next slide please
so we then think of how we're going to
form the beads and consider chemical
routes for example pearl polymerization
or should it be emulsion polymerization
or should it be the nylon rope trick
which is in the facial polymerization
between two different liquid phases or
should it be produced from an
oscillating jet that produces beads into
a stream that convex them away and then
they set up there of course is a set of
processing questions that we will
address and then the next slide please
how do we and we probably thought about
this this is a poor place for this we
must have thought about this concept
much earlier on how will we get the
beads away from the liquid centrifuge
them well we can if they have a density
difference but obviously if they're
exactly neutrally buoyant that won't
work
should they be micro filtered through a
micro filtration screen by magnetic
field or can we use an electric field to
separate them and the next slide please
here is another example of chemical
processing how should we make this
active surface on the bead shall we
activate
for example polystyrene beads with
sulfur trioxide to form the ion exchange
beads styrene sulfonate shall we use
radiation grafting to put on some kind
of a monomer on top of these supporting
sphere shall we covalently bind a ligand
such as protein aid to the bead surface
in order to scavenge out monoclonal
antibody leaving every other protein in
the soup behind next slide please
and now we turn to the broader technical
issues in the next outer ring and in the
next slide please
what are the hazards in the manufacture
of these beads and in the utilization by
the customer in the manufacturing
process for example with styrene and dye
vinyl benzene could you have a fire
which you have an explosion are the
workers in the plant subjected to
fumes that are long-term or short-term
toxic if for example vinyl chloride were
involved in this manufacture or if
benzene were it would be an extremely
hazardous thing to do in utilization by
the customers suppose clinical
technicians using beads that have been
intended to harvest human immune a virus
are exposed to the beads with the virus
on it there is a tremendous issue of
health hazard involved next slide please
and that of course brings up the same
parallel question who are going to be
the watchdogs on this process of
manufacturing OSHA environmental
protection agency the Food and Drug
Administration and if so what do they
require us as manufacturers to do in
making the product and in conveying the
product to the customer under under what
conditions can we do that and with what
notices of caution and warranty next
slide please
and then a very interesting issue it's a
it's both a technical issue and it goes
beyond that in terms of patent
protection should it be sought on the
product for making for the bees
themselves or should it be sought on the
product process or on both or is this
product we're going to make so peculiar
that it would be very difficult for
anybody else to find out how to make it
and therefore we could practice it
secretly these issues we will debate in
class because I will be joined in a
debate with or a patent attorney who is
a chemical engineer from Hamilton Smith
and Brook will join me and we'll debate
for two sessions the pros and cons of
this and he from his point of view as a
chemical engineer and patent attorney
will debate with me I like this the foil
I was for fits my score and I put some
very stupid questions in and then he
gets kind of slapped me down next slide
please
product failure what can we as the
manufacturers do inadvertently to cause
the product to fail for example let it
freeze overheat it let it dry out when
it should not and what can the customer
inadvertently due to cause the product
to fail well he might for example if the
if the beats were to be kept damp he
might let them dry out if they were to
be stored at four Celsius he might let
them get up to maybe forty degrees
Celsius one day and they lose their
activity in each case what damage will
result well for example in a diagnostic
test if the beads are intended to
demonstrate disease in a patient
carrying a disease by an antibody and
ijen reaction and the ligand on the bead
has died because of heat exposure and so
the test gives a false negative the
customer is in serious trouble and
therefore probably the manufacturer is
because of the liability running
backwards from user to manufacturer so
we have to consider these issues and the
next slide gives you an example of tired
beads I call them they get very tired as
you can see they're not feeling well and
if they were to be deployed in a liquid
mixture they probably shatter into their
component pieces this happens to be
beads ion-exchange beads that should
have been kept damp
were allowed dry out really dry out and
you can see the stresses that produced
failures but this is only a mechanical
failure that's not so bad as having the
total catastrophic biological medical
failure that would be involved in a
diagnostic test next slide please
and then we come to the issues beyond
technical us and for example next slide
please
we have to consider these issues of
centering around the market who are the
customers what do they say they want and
is this the same thing that you think
there really could use do they need
beads or should they have something else
we will address those issues the next
one next slide please
as well as that of who are the
competitors and how could we
differentiate the product we're making
from those products already on the
market and the next slide please
and the markets specifically what
markets are we target targeting and how
will we get the product to them
distribute them through distributors or
market than ourselves and address this
whole set of issues we're going to have
as a guest lecturer a vice president of
marketing from in
stray in an industry like one that would
be appropriate to the this product to
debate these issues with us next slide
please
the question of how do we price the
product if we have the market leaders we
have some latitude and putting the price
about where we want to but if we have
competition obviously that's not
possible and the issues of course going
back to hazards what other hazards to
the public art of the user and what is
what is the liability to us as
manufacturers if things go wrong can we
be wiped out next slide please
I've given you an example of a
technology driven case but as an
opposite example we will consider
briefly for example starting with a
market need and we see that there is a
certain need in the market to do
something and we select a solution see
out of many different solutions ABCD and
so on and we look at the immediate
technical issues and the possible
solutions and then that conveys us into
the broad technical issues beyond that
next slide please
and for example what as as a case in the
in the manufacture of beer one problem
is to remove the haze farming proteins
before it's bottled otherwise the beer
will become cloudy one method of doing
this is to use the polymer of polyvinyl
pyrrolidone we have if we want to do
this in beer this sub-options of using
it as a high molecular weight polymer to
remove by ultra filtration or
cross-linked as a film or cross-linked
dis hydrogel beads are grafted to
polystyrene beads and so on and so forth
and we will select for for various
reasons that we would discuss this is a
market driven case and if as the final
slide which is really where we started a
technology driven one and there are two
ways of approaching this thing which we
and the students will discuss either
there's a market need which we must
address or there's in this case exciting
new technology which we don't really
know our priori what we're going to do
with it but we could do ABCD and so on
and maybe we're going to select q is the
opportunity and then look at the
how to ring the market who is in the
market all already is there anybody
there is a crowded as our niche is there
any market maybe there is no market for
it can the market be developed beyond
this conceptual desire and so this moves
out and as I started my comments with my
my gratitude to the pleasure of having
worked with students over the years and
one of the great privileges of being an
MIT professor is the excitement that the
students bring to us they keep us young
I was born in the year of PCE but I
still feel young because of the students
that I have associated world and I
associate but now if it weren't for them
I feel very old but beyond the student
says my teachers and they are my
professors at MIT at McAdams quitman
Gilliland Louis there are other teachers
I had who have affected me anonymously
in especially in the context of what I
just presented to you from my early
experience in industry a number of MIT
alumni and Causton alumni Bradley Dewey
who if there ever was a an equal to doc
Lewis he must have been it true Giants
rolling at each other from quite a sight
Bradley Barry president of Dwight on the
chemical and I worked although I wasn't
supposed to in the in the flowchart of
hierarchy I was the low man on the totem
pole but I reported directly to Dewey
when he wanted to call me into his
office and for Charles AMI and for
George John lund and if he who Ferguson
and Fordham Shanklin who's here today
for whom I worked for many years first
as a comply at Dorian Army and then as a
consultant to that corporation and so
I'm enormously thankful to the to the
exposure to the world of Industry that
they gave me and to many others in
industry whom I've worked with with with
joy over the years and I'm absolutely
delighted to see all of all of my former
students here and to see all of you here
today
thanks for coming
you